Yesterday, rising Republican star Daniel Cameron,
who's the attorney general of Kentucky, announced
charges against officers involved in the fatal
shooting by police of black woman Briona Taylor
and very few charges were outlined.
And now protests and unrest are once again
rising.
And we're going to talk about all of it as
a reminder.
The story here is of 26 year old Briona Taylor,
who was killed in her own home when three
Louisville, Kentucky, police officers executed
what's known as a no knock warrant.
We've talked about no knock warrants many
times before and the the serious concerns
about the use of no knock warrants, particularly
related to drug crimes.
This was related to a drug investigation.
Daniel Cameron said, listen, officers did
announce themselves as they executed the no
knock warrant.
Of course, the big picture, the red alert
is that officers used this warrant to search
Briona Taylor's home for someone who did not
live there.
No drugs were found in the apartment.
And what ultimately transpired is that Briona
Taylor's boyfriend having no idea that it
was law enforcement in their home because
remember, there were no drugs there.
The person they were looking for wasn't there.
Brianna Taylor's boyfriend started shooting
in what he believed was self-defense from
potentially an armed intruder.
And Briona Taylor ended up killed in the gunfight
that ensued.
Now, one other note before we outline the
charges.
Yesterday's announcement was about criminal
The civil peace was settled last week.
The city settled the lawsuit against the three
officers involved.
The lawsuit was brought by Brianna Taylor's
mother.
And the city has agreed to pay to meet Tamika
Polmar 12 million dollars, and they've agreed
to enact police reforms.
Now, in terms of the criminal charges, one
of the three officers charged with wanton
endangerment.
Wanton endangerment.
And that is not actually related to the death
of Briona Taylor, the wanton endangerment
is because of the discharge of the officers
firearm inside of the apartment.
It put neighbors at risk.
That's the charge.
Two other officers who fired shots not charged
at all.
So, in essence, nobody was charged for the
actual killing of Briona Taylor.
This has predictably led to significant unrest
and protests have started.
And the protests continue to build.
And it's quite possible that the next 24,
48, 72, 96 hours are going to see even more
of it.
Authorities saying that two officers were
shot and wounded last night in Louisville.
The interim Louisville police chief, Robert
Schroeder, said that they have a suspect in
custody but did not release too many additional
details.
We saw demonstrations and marches in cities
including New York, Chicago, Washington, D.C.,
Atlanta, Philadelphia, just massive crowds.
We have video of the crowd in Brooklyn near
the Barclays Center, my sort of old stomping
grounds when I lived in Brooklyn.
That crowd eventually walked over the Manhattan
Bridge and connected with another protest
in Manhattan, in Chinatown and in surrounding
neighborhoods.
And we are seeing these all over the country
in addition to unrest that did become more
violent in Louisville, Kentucky, which is
the epicenter of this case.
And again, overwhelmingly peaceful protesters
with some provocateurs as as you typically
see.
So there's a few different things here.
Let's do the political first, maybe politically.
I still think this is bad for Donald Trump.
This unrest related to racially tinged events
is not good for Donald Trump.
Now, Donald Trump and some of his supporters
continue to say these protests are a preview
of Joe Biden's America.
There will be more of this if Joe Biden is
president.
I believe most Americans see this and they
see it as part of the failures of the Trump
administration.
Part of the failure of the ideology that Donald
Trump espouses on police use of force.
And we're seeing it reflected in the polls.
We don't really have to wonder after corona
virus in the economy.
The third most important issue right now is
this.
It's race relations and this unrest and law
enforcement.
And Donald Trump's approval on that issue
is very, very low.
So I reject the idea that this helps Donald
Trump.
More importantly is the issue of justice.
We have a criminal legal system that is meant
to protect officers.
Now you can debate to what degree should officers
be protected.
And I am the first to tell you that to some
degree they should be protected in the sense
that being a police officer is a potentially
more dangerous job than being an accountant
or being a teacher or being a cashier.
And so some degree of protection makes sense
for officers.
The degree to which the default is we ere
on the side of the benefit of the doubt for
the officers, that is allowing justice to
not be served.
So, you know, I've given you the list before.
We need demilitarization of police.
We need special prosecutors to investigate
police, implicit bias training.
OK, fixing the war on drugs are Bad Actors
database.
It's a very long list, ten or twelve items
which I've outlined.
But the precedent that is potentially set
here is horrifying.
If you have ever been associated with anyone
who is potentially a criminal, the police
can in certain states issue a no knock warrant,
go into where you're you're you're living
and you can end up shot dead with essentially
no repercussions.
Defending your home is not a defense in many
of these cases.
And remember, there was a grand jury that
looked at a case.
We covered it.
I think I don't know if it was a year or two
years ago at this point.
There was a case of a woman who fired a warning
shot to get her husband to her husband, was
approaching her and was abusive.
She fired a warning shot in the garage and
it hit drywall.
She was charged more seriously than these
officers.
OK, that doesn't make sense.
So the system is hugely failing us.
We will see the degree to which unrest continues
in the next few days.
But this is what we've been covering this
for a long time.
There's nothing new here.
But the way in which it is now playing a role
in the presidential election is certainly
something the timing of which could have political
influence.
And again, I do not believe it will be good
for Donald Trump.